we're now joined by megan's sister
lamaya
hi lamaya
and um your cousin dijon and i'm so glad
to meet you now dijon
i think we've actually met before we
have
we have met before yes yes yes before
the pandemic when we could all like
actually dance in close quarters and be
upon each other
he told us he told us the story because
when i told him that we were doing the
show
he was like oh my god that's so crazy
tell them stories
look at the funny part is i also took
megan to that same exact dance class
so when she was like we're doing this
show i was like funny enough that same
dance class that you and i went to i was
dancing next to drew barrymore
by the way that is my number one
favorite class it's like
literally being transported into the
movie fame
and like dancing your heart out to like
the coolest
music and style it's my favorite that's
dope that she showed up to the dance
classes
i am the biggest his name is kenneth
marquis and he's a phenomenon and anyone
who is lucky enough to go to these
classes it's like
you feel like you've entered a parallel
universe because it's just so raw and
real
okay so you guys all host a talk show
together called
cousins and i would love to be i've seen
the show and i would love to be a guest
on cousins is that presumptuous
yes well we would love you to be a guest
on customers so
here's how we like to intro our show i'm
megan
i'm lamaya and i'm dejean and we are
young cousins
so um we would love to ask you a few
questions today
um one of the questions i wanted to ask
who is somebody
that you've met along the way a woman
that happened to be super
badass that you ended up actually
becoming like friends
slash family with after the fact and you
didn't expect it
well um i just hearkened back to this
woman named linda opps
she is a producer and she produced a
bunch of films we've all heard of
but we were on this movie of a female
western and
it kind of was a troubled production and
there was this little tiny woman
running around and problem solving it's
like
i admired her so much and i became
friends with her because i didn't like
being an actress on the sidelines
watching
problems not get solved i wanted to be
like
her and she mentored me and she really
did change my life and i
shortly thereafter open flower films
when i was 19 years old
um because she paved the way for me
to see how to do that wow yeah
totally can relate to that yeah let's
keep it going um we have
another segment we wanted to ask you
another question we're going to let him
go into this we did want to ask you
another question we have this segment we
usually do called going viral yes yes
usually whatever is pop culture things
that are going on
we like to get the families uh take on
things so dj
wants to ask you a little well well i
know that you
you and i drew enjoy a good dance class
a good cardio class so right now the all
the rave
and hey get it get it
[Music]
out you feel so cool in kennesa's class
too it's like
all dork dumb goes out the window and
you just believe in yourself go on sorry
but all the raid right now is because
we're in a pandemic is group classes
even like a pelican or online so i
wanted to know have you got
into group classes from your home yet
and if you haven't yet would you
um i totally would and sadly no one
has really brought that uh to the table
i work out with this one woman
um uh named katrina rini and
she's changed my life and i work out
with her
all the time and um so i am i am
active but i will say of all the things
that we ask ourselves what we miss in
the world group
classes is definitely high on my list
i miss yoga and pilates class working
that core
and looking out like i don't look so bad
i know well
maybe soon i can be back out in los
angeles with you and we can all take
kenneth's class together
that would be the best we're
oh i'm so grateful to have gotten to do
this show with you
megan i just am blown away by all of
your accomplishments
and lamaya and dijon i love cousins and
everything you guys do
and if not now when is available in
theaters and on demand and digital
right now this was such a pleasure and
we have a date in the future
we do we do looking forward to body
rolling inappropriately
all right all right all right you guys i
will see you soon thank you so much
and we will be right back
[Music]
you